[Music]
self-driving cars are usually high-end
expensive machines you could drop a
hundred grand on a Tesla or try to get a
ride in a self driving uber but their
cars and the likes of Google's are so
laden with the very latest tech that
they're way out of reach for personal
ownership one spinning lidar sensor can
cost tens of thousands of dollars alone
ion diet wants to change that
the Korean car maker is joining the
ever-growing field of autonomous
wannabes and it's testing its creations
in Las Vegas Nevada is the state of
choice for many automakers to test their
driverless machines here is the coveted
red autonomous vehicle plate so this car
is legal to drive itself here with
certain restrictions it's paired this
time though with a Hyundai badge
the automaker is here trying to prove
its serious about bringing driverless
cars to the masses Hyundai is building
self-driving prototypes on its ionic
platform which comes as a regular hybrid
a plug-in hybrid or a pure electric and
it says the idea is to make a
self-driving car at a price point
attainable by an average buyer not just
throw tech at a project and then try to
cut costs afterwards key to its
approaches detailed mapping but it also
uses three cheaper lidar laser units
integrated into the front bumper as well
as four cameras and three radars it
worked well enough on a pre-planned
course in Las Vegas if a little
hesitantly
and the various sensors all around us
checking around the vehicle presumably
before we make a turn like that to make
sure there wasn't a cycle alongside us
ioneiy is working to reduce the
computing power needed to the bare
minimum as that saves both cost and
energy consumption it will show off this
car at CES the Consumer Electronics Show
but it will be showing the road with
tons of other prototypes it's a key time
for manufacturers to demonstrate their
abilities as car makers ride sharers and
technology companies all work hard to
propel us towards a self-driving future
[Music]